cette chanson c'est inspirant policiers
reçoivent une formation de près de 20
heures en maintien et rétablissement de
l'ordre
et le contenu a été révisé après une
manifestation étudiante de 2012 on dit
souvent avec le recul 2012 était un
laboratoire immense attend de dôme et au
rétablissement de l'ordre au québec le
nom même à l'apprentissage
ce laboratoire c'est en fait plus de
mille trois cent soixante dix
manifestations québec entre février et
septembre 2012 en sept mois il ya une
près de 3500 d'arrestation et parfois
des blessés
à chaque soir à 8h30 c'était un point de
ralliement pour des manifestations de ce
soir linde qu'est l'île étaient des
manifestations étudiantes en 2012
aujourd'hui il travaille pour un
organisme qu'il défend notamment le
droit de manifester
selon elle plusieurs pratiques de
l'époque que les arrestations masse ont
nui à ce droit démocratique ç'a eu
l'effet à la fois de
dissuader beaucoup de personnes et en
même temps ça a créé aussi un sentiment
de colère chez beaucoup d'autres
personnes le travail policier a aussi
été dénoncé par plusieurs depuis dix ans
des tribunaux et des comités de
déontologie ont donné raison à certains
manifestants blessés ou arrêtés pendant
les événements c'est le constat
principal qu'on peut tirer de 2012 ce
qu'elle a la police a agi à beaucoup de
moments sans égard à la vie et à la
sécurité des manifestants font rien
garder les mange à demi dose et vous
dire cela ce serait problématique bon on
pourra
en 2012 pierre savard travaillé au
service de la police de montréal son
constat les patrouilles art dépêchés sur
les lieux ne sont pas suffisamment
formés contrairement aux escouades
spécialisées classé d'être coordonnée
depuis l'école nationale de police a
suivi les recommandations du rapport
ménard publié en 2014
repenser la formation et ça commence par
une enseignement théorique je me sens
beaucoup sur leurs connaissances que les
policiers doivent avoir sur la liberté
d'expression et le droit aux gens de
s'exprimer
la deuxième condamnation tout rapport
c'était con et 6 avec nous la police est
arrivée sur la gestion du stress et des
émotions on se rappelle tous des snacks
qui ont eu lieu dans lors des événements
2012 on est dans l'opposition moi je
m'attends un policier cap avenir des 63
qui étaient très disciplinés on va
travailler en équipe tu vas prendre soin
de ses partenaires à côté puisqu'ils
passeront pas dans un échange verbal
avec des manifestants au pas de garde
l'enseignement mais aussi davantage sur
d'arrestations ciblées d'individus qui
commettent des actes criminels
contrairement aux arrestations de masse
qu'on a vu en 2012 on élimine un paquet
contravention on arrêtait déjà les gens
contestez donc les décisions des
tonneaux en fait en sorte que c'est une
pratique qui est plus rue n'est plus
retenu présent la formation sur
l'utilisation des armes d'impact n'ait
pas donné par l'école nationale mais
plutôt par les services policiers qui
ont des escouades spécialisées ccl2 ce
plot convoi comme ici à la sûreté du
québec depuis 2002 comment les
interventions ont évolué au sénat est ce
que je vous remonterez même au sommet
des amériques en 2009 on était en mode
on pourra dire protection après soyez
montebello protection d'un endroit
victoriaville protection d'un centre de
congrès est là maintenant on est plus en
encadrement dès le début des faut le
voir ici dans nos locaux il faut
toujours être prêt intervenez les gens
terrain doivent avoir une
requalification pour pouvoir participer
à ce genre d'événement l'eau les armes
d'impact utilisé par là et ce qu ils ne
sont plus les mêmes qu'il ya dix ans
mais ce sont pour des raisons
technologiques qu elles ont été
remplacées et non pas juridique
toutefois selon claude germain qui
étaient sur le terrain en 2002 à
victoriaville les agents habilités à les
utiliser sont aujourd'hui moins nombreux
c'est un groupe
maintenant spécialisé le conte à la
sûreté du québec pour utiliser les armes
d'internet en un paquet projective
à l'instar de la sûreté du québec le
service de la police de la ville de
montréal forme aussi ses propres équipes
d'intervention mais notre demande
d'entrevue a été refusée car des
procédures judiciaires liées aux
évènements de 2002 sont toujours en
cours on ne confirme toutefois que les
grenades assourdissantes ont été retirés
de leurs équipements leurs stratégies
aussi c'est comme de contenir donc
malgré les changements opérés depuis
2012 linda gail il voudrait bien voir
les gouvernements s'impliquent davantage
on peut dire avec certitude que 2012
pourrait se reproduire dans quelques
années puis on peut le dire parce que
il n'y a pas eu le retrait des armes de
contrôle de foule puis ça c'est la toute
première chose à faire le problème c'est
qu'on peut pas être contre plus de
formation mais la formation ça agit au
niveau individuel donc ça agit sur le
policier mais la preuve le problème les
pains individuels et institutionnels
seule fois où on est rendu par rapport
aux monnaies de cas sévères et quant à
lui optimisme est persuadé que la
formation révisé fera la différence pour
les aspirants policiers ou la journée
vous avez vu même une manifestation qui
est un peu plus passe-t-il en valais
policiers devraient être contents de
l'avoir parce qu'un paquet policiers qui
étaient sur le terrain
qui avait pour le niveau de formation
qui ont actuellement
[Musique]